hey guys what's going on there's a
couple of big stories this past week in
the crypto markets the first one is that
Genesis the big lending organization has
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy now
they're reporting that there are about a
hundred thousand creditors that have
almost 11 billion dollars of claims
against the organization this decision
to file for bankruptcy comes after the
SEC filed claims against both Genesis
and Gemini as many of you know Gemini
and Genesis have been fighting it out in
public because Gemini had taken about
900 million dollars of their customer
funds and lent them to Genesis but
Genesis got caught in all the contagion
from The Lending across the crypto
markets we'll continue to watch that
story but if we fast forward to see
someone else who's already in bankruptcy
there's a story out on FTX and John Ray
who's the new CEO who claims that
they've found up to five billion dollars
of crypto assets and they also are
considering restarting the exchange now
this shouldn't come as a surprise to
many people FTX was a big business they
had a lot of Revenue and it seemed to be
a heralded asset in the crypto ecosystem
but John Ray and the current team don't
exactly know how to run a crypto
exchange and so it'll be interesting to
see how much they'll be able to restart
and whether they really will try to make
it all back by simply turning on the
exchange a third story from this week
was that the doj the SEC and many other
law enforcement organizations and
Regulators came together to create a new
enforcement action on a little-known
exchange called bits lato that exchange
is now alleged to have money laundered
over 700 million dollars which is a big
number but this came as a surprise to
the crypto Community because not a lot
of people had ever heard of this
exchange nor did they realize that it
had nearly this much volume to be able
to siphon off 700 million dollars
through money laundering schemes next up
Jamie Diamond everyone's favorite Bank
CEO he was at Davos and he said that
Bitcoin was a hype up fraud which
doesn't make a lot of sense and it shows
that maybe some of the large Banks and
their executive teams still do not
understand how exactly this technology
Works nor what the potential future
promise of it is but on the other hand
we also had Bank of America another
large Bank come out and say that they
believe that stable coins are the future
of payments and money but not just any
type of stable coin Bank of America
specifically is zeroing in on Central
Bank digital currencies which don't yet
exist but central banks seem to be very
interested in and so if we zoom out and
we look at the week in crypto we can see
that the Legacy Banks they're all
confused they actually are taking
different approaches Jamie dimon thinks
that Bitcoin isn't worth anything it's a
hyped up fraud Bank of America believes
that cbdc's are going to be the future
and at the same time law enforcement and
Regulators are coming down hard on
various crypto exchanges that they're
accusing of doing negative things and
then there are multiple organization
that are either already in bankruptcy or
now are beginning to enter that chapter
11 Court proceeding ultimately the
crypto Market is in chaos and we will
continue to see The Fallout from FTX and
many of the other things that transpired
in the second half of the year but as we
know Bitcoin continues to produce block
after block after block of transactions
and it seems like many of the investors
The Operators the employees and the
market participants across crypto remain
as bullish as before that's it for this
week I'll talk to you guys next week